we gave you work paid you well and after  all the kindness  we showed you you want to leave us come  on mina  but you said you had a money guy you  remember that right petey  my dad is not a patient man when it  comes to his money  so where's carl i don't know  he switched branches he's at the stanlow  bank on clark and fourth took one minute  to sell out your brother  one minute let him go or i'll shoot you  in the face with this gun  what are you gonna blow off my big toe  no your face okay well right now you're  at my kneecap you're gonna kneecap me  that's my vagina you're gonna shoot me  in the vagina no i respect that area  yeah you respect that area  rita oh it's not nice to point guns at  people  [Music]  you